all right Kim so where are we left off
Lincoln gets elected in November of 1860
he's not inaugurated until we get into
1861 shortly after his inauguration you
have the whole situation at Fort Sumter
which is really the the start of the
Civil War we don't have the first major
battle until we get to Bull Run and the
overall I guess you could say theatres
of war we have this corridor here in the
Northeast and Virginia and Maryland and
you also have it in the West along the
Mississippi and the north the strategy
is well let's use our industrial base
let's use our larger population let's
use our Navy to see if we can stop if we
can essentially blockade the south while
the South's I say we have the homecourt
we have better leadership we we just
need to outlast the north and so what
happens as we get started we talked
about Bull Run being the the first major
battle who kind of comes out comes out
better in some of these first
engagements well I think it's a surprise
to everyone when the South does much
better in the first year of the war than
the north knowing the major advantage is
that the North has an industrial power
and railroads and just in the sheer
number of people it's very surprising
that the leadership in the south does
such an incredible job of really
blocking the North's advances that the
north is attempting to take Richmond and
Lee repeatedly keeps general McClellan
from getting to Richmond and and then
Lee actually goes on the offensive to
some degree I mean he's the South's
essentially wins the bull run and they
have a series of victories as you
mentioned in year one right so one
problem that the north has is that
Lincoln's generals are just not nearly
as skilled George B McClellan that we've
talked about his idea of the South's
power is perhaps considerably greater
than the South's actual power is he is
forever telling Lincoln
I need more troops I need more supplies
sent me more things he loves
his army but I think he was actually a
little too close to the troops himself
he was really afraid to lose anyone
which made him very popular with the
army but drove Lincoln crazy because the
the north comes out with this really
strong numeric and industrial advantage
and as McClellan delays it gives the
South time to build things up over and
over again in fact Lincoln who we often
think of as being sort of this great
grandfather Lee sweet character who has
so many words of wisdom his letters to
McClellan are downright snarky he says
to McClellan if you're not using the
army could I borrow it so and is that
what historians believe - I mean it
looks like Lincoln felt that the reason
why year one went in favor of the south
and and you know when we talk about in
previous leaders everyone thought
there's going to be a fast engagement
the North had all of these advantages
for Lincoln believe that maybe was
machlin wasn't being aggressive enough
yes absolutely I do historians believe
that - yeah I know I think that's that's
true it's really borne out by the
numbers that in many cases where
McClellan thought he was facing just
thousands of troops he was really only
facing a fraction of that and so that
made him be a little bit more he was
very cautious and so what at what point
is a turning point at least in this
these early stages of the so for us we
have here on this timeline ago we go
from April 1861 to roughly April 1865
the first year so I couldn't let me I
could draw that so the first year would
be roughly roughly this so we would then
we get a get we've had several battles
but after Bull Run but then we get to
Antietam right so Lee since he's done so
well in Virginia he decides that he's
gonna take the army to the north this is
the first time that he heads up into the
border state of Maryland and he meets at
Antietam Creek with McClellan and this
goes back to the naming conventions
between the north and south it's called
Antietam that's the body of water which
this which to the north does this is
Antietam right there right well the
South refers to it as the nearby
town which is Sharpsburg Maryland I see
once this is a big deal this is the
South invading the north and out taking
the offensive right and this is the
bloodiest day in American history when
let me make sure I digest that what you
just said the bloodiest day so even I I
imagine things like Pearl Harbor and
d-day right so 4,000 Americans died on a
single day September 17th 1862 when
these two armies meet at Antietam and on
no other day in American history have so
many Americans died not even on
September 11th did that many Americans
die and was this a surprise to folks
yeah well I think one of the one of the
truisms perhaps about military strategy
in general is that people are always
planning for the last war mm-hmm they're
not planning for the next war and so
they learn from their mistakes but what
they don't know how to do always is
anticipate what's going to be new about
this war and there were so many new
inventions during this time period that
really made the Civil War an incredibly
deadly war yeah and you can see I mean
these are pictures these are Antietam
right here this is Antietam yes and this
is actually looks like Lincoln and
McClellan right meeting at Antietam
which is incredibly but and you talk
about new technologies or new weapons
this this this this rifle here looks
like one of them yes so this is a war
where there's a transition from the
musket to the rifle and what's different
about a rifle is that inside the barrel
of a rifle there is a sort of spiral
shaped groove and the spiral shaped
groove makes the rifle much more
accurate at a much farther distance it's
sort of the distant the the difference
between just hurling a football
end-over-end
and throwing a spiral so you can hit a
target at 600 yards which is much for a
musket or hard very hard with the musket
so it gets the bullet spinning which
keeps it on a stretcher better exactly
so we have much more accurate technology
and you know old military strategy if
you you know see paintings of for
example the Napoleonic Wars just
involved a whole bunch of soldiers
lining up and going toward each other
well when you've got soldiers in a line
and very accurate weapons I never got
why that ever made sense I'm not sure I
do either
yeah great military strategist you know
wearing these you know bright uniforms
and marching in step you know and these
kind of yeah it does seem to make you a
very good target yes yes but anyway you
have the rifle now much more accurate
and and you end up with with scenes like
this but what was the outcome of at
Antietam well there are there are two
very major outcomes of Antietam I would
say one on the negative side for the
north is this is a battle that is widely
photographed as you can see Mathew Brady
who was the leading photography studio
owner of his time and it's won t Matthew
okay yeah very important only one two
yes non traditional spelling amenities
he sends out his photographer that works
for him named Alexander Gardner and they
have roving photographers for the first
time they have wagons and they took
photography is just becoming a used
technology ring and so they have
Alexander Gardner photograph the
battlefields at Antietam and as you can
see okay
er that's right yes as you can see this
is just about as far away from the kind
of heroic paintings of what battles
looks like that people had been used to
seeing up until this point these don't
look like you know the sort of heroes of
the Revolutionary War like George
Washington this is gruesome
this is gruesome and this is really
fascinating cuz we take it for granted
in today
day and age is that the effect of media
on people's perception of things like
war before the the camera before
photographs if I'm a civilian I just
hear about these you know these great
stories and I see these paintings that
look very valiant and very heroic but
now with photographs you see the grim
reality of war I mean people just shot
in their tracks and you know young men
just you know it kind of just piled up
if it's very dark and a lot of the yeah
and it's a real PR problem for the north
because this is before we can really put
photography in newspapers they don't
have that technology yet but these
photographs were put on display in
Brady's Studios he had one in Washington
DC and one in New York City and people
would go and look at these photographs
and it was very shocking to them it was
a level of detail that they had never
seen in some cases they could make out
the faces of the individual men who were
dead on the battlefield and that just
seemed you know beyond what was
imaginable to these people to think of
some poor person going into one of these
studios and seeing their son dead there
on the battlefield made it very
difficult for the north to keep up
morale fascinating